Linda you welcome to trigonometry good
to be here welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is a show for you if you were
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
we're here the world-famous angel comedy
club and our amazing expert guest this
week is an economist author and
broadcaster Linda you welcome to
trigonometry good to be here
[Music]
Linda would you tell us a little bit
about your personal story about how you
came to be literally sitting on this
seat in your career well I'm an
economist I'm also a broadcaster so I am
at Oxford University I'm also at London
Business School and so but that's part
of what I do the other part of what I do
is I'm also a broadcaster so I have
presented a number of TV and radio
programmes for the BBC I was the BBC's
chief business correspondent I was
economics editor at Bloomberg TV so I
find myself in a very well a very fun
mix of things to do so doing teaching
economics researching economics but also
getting to talk about economics and I
have just finished a book that brings
both of those sides together talking
about economics in an accessible way to
a non specialist audience basically
normal people like the great economist
how their ideas can help us today oh and
I'm reading at the moment it's
absolutely fascinating I was just saying
to you before we started the show that
it's eminently readable for people who
are not specialists in economics thank
you I guess we've talked about a moment
ago one of the quotes I always have in
the back of my mind is that the former
US congressman Dick Armey defined
economics as the science of telling you
things you've known your whole life but
in a language that you can't understand
that's why we do the show we would try
and break more complex things down when
we bring on amazing experts like you to
actually explain to us what we're trying
to understand so you talk about the big
challenges that the economists of the
past could help us address and how their
ideas could do that
and the number one challenge that I
think you raised in the book early on
this growth right that's something that
you bring center stage and this is going
to sound like a very stupid question but
why is growth important
growth is important because it gives
people a sense of possibility about the
future so if you think about countries
which are stagnant so actually Japan
comes to mind it's a rich countries the
world's third biggest economy but it's
essentially being stagnant for about
three decades and when you go to Japan
you get a sense that people are not that
optimistic about their future and so I
think one of the most important things
about thinking about how economies can
grow is what possibilities for
employment for entrepreneurship it
offers so that people can look to the
future and say yeah you know I think the
future looks brighter and I think that's
probably the main reason why you condom
is look at growth but I would also say
especially for rich countries I think
we're in a privileged position where we
can think about the quality of growth so
in the book I stress that it's not just
the speed of growth it's actually the
kind of society that you want to live in
so one of the chapters is called is
inequality inevitable and so by taking a
more holistic view about why why we will
look at economics as a way a set of
tools to get you outcomes such as better
economic prospects but also creating a
society with good standards of living
less inequality for everyone I think
that's where the economic tools are
really useful but I should stress the
aim of how much inequality or what shape
the society takes that's those are
political aims economics is the tools to
help you analyze the route to get there
or not to get there now it's very
interesting you were talking about
inequality I've been reading a lot
recently about how the Millennial
Generation are actually going to be the
one of the first generations that are
essentially less well-off than the
previous and the baby boomers do you
think that that is going to be a major
problem for society I think it is I
think in Britain I think a lot of that
is seen in the housing market so I think
the latest figures say that
people over the age of 50 control
three-quarters of the housing wealth in
the country well and and in America the
idea of the American Dream is that
regardless of your background you have
the ability to move up and that's also
not really true anymore and so I think
that will have implications for this
kind of outlook towards the future that
I was describing a moment ago and that's
why I think looking hard at how you can
resolve economic challenges like slow
growth inequality and all these things
should be front and center in terms of
our public debates debates on podcast
like this going on that debate then you
talk about you mentioned the housing
kind of people holding onto housing
Colden Francis and I have been talking
about this all the time and one of the
things I was I was I was saying was it's
not Russian oligarchs and Chinese
billionaires that are doing this it's
actually in my opinion this is the
government policy of propping up the
housing market does that make any
economic sense or am i talking nonsense
no no I think the EM they help to buy
scheme for instance the government has
implemented it helps first-time buyers
get onto the housing ladder but the if
you have the same supply of housing but
you up demand your housing there has the
effect of raising house prices so that's
not quite solving the problem which is
you need a bigger supply of housing
that's affordable because higher supply
pushes down prices house prices it makes
it more affordable for people so I think
that is that is spot on I think there
are ways the housing market could be
regulated and at the moment we're just
not really seeing enough supply so we
need to build more homes on the on the
one hand but on the other hand if
politically it's a massive problem for
the government that house prices fall
because people feel less wealthier they
then don't vote for the party but cause
that's got the wealth effect
is that something that's ever gonna get
fixed I mean if it politically innit
electorally
it makes no sense to do the right thing
in this in the sense is that yeah is
ever gonna change I think one of the
reasons why housing is always on the
agenda there are new initiatives now for
instance to take away land from councils
which are not a building number of
houses is because of the issue we talked
about a moment ago which is inequality
so if you have a great intergenerational
divide the younger people who are part
of generation rent if they can't get on
the housing ladder or feel it's going to
be out of reach for probably until
they're into their middle age that is
not going to make for a happy electorate
so those are voters so yes there's there
certainly you wanted the housing market
to be buoyant you want prices to be -
nothing nothing dramatic happening to
prices but I think if even the baby
boomers would say that no one really
expects the housing market to be rising
the way that it used to and maybe that's
a good thing because it does increase
the prospect that younger people can get
on the housing ladder and that would
help with social cohesion and
importantly as I said a moment ago
they are also voters yes they could
voice their dissatisfaction at the polls
it was quite interesting as you touched
on the United States and you were saying
about the American dream which is to
better yourself and to you know it
essentially rise up through the rungs of
society and you touched upon the fact
that that really doesn't seem to exist
anymore are you sort of saying Linda
that the American Dream is dying
I think the I think the American dream
is has always been an aspiration I'm not
sure if the economic reality really
matched has matched it for some time
this is actually work done by Joseph
Stiglitz the Nobel laureate his latest
book actually traces I think the
disconnect between what the American
dream represents and the reality of a
lack of social mobility for lots of
young Americans so what is the American
dream
white picket fence a house a good job I
think that's sort of the trappings of it
and you're the aspiring thinking you can
do that regardless of your own
background is part of what makes gifts I
think America the sense of
entrepreneurship that it's had because
when one sets America is pretty
extraordinary right the world's biggest
economy very technologically advanced
and they keep producing innovation and
innovators is not like anyone sits rest
on their laurels so that is still there
and there and there and they are there
are some who still break through the
ranks they come from nothing and they
end up tech billionaires or what have
you but in Stiglitz this book he
documents that for lots of the American
public doing better than your parents
isn't likely to happen and so that's I
think one worrying trend in America so a
couple of economic trends to behind that
which I do also discuss in my book is
that quite extraordinarily median income
so that's the income of the person in
the middle of the income distribution
the very rich the very poor median
incomes have been stagnant in America
for four decades so that means that
America's economy has grown GDP per
capita average incomes have grown but
that's going to the the wealthy so that
means that for the average person
incomes have stagnated for a very long
time and the middle class which is
defined as those in the middle of the
income spectrum that has now shrunk to
be less than half of the American
population for the first time since at
least the 1970s so you have a shrinking
middle class stagnant incomes 40 years
in a country that by all accounts is a
rich country with lots of great
innovators and I think that divided
really suggests the American Dream is
possible for some before a lot it's not
really it's not it's not a reality for
them it's not within their grasp and
that's very interesting and another
question which to us is two questions
actually how much of a part does race
play in that is it are you more likely
to succeed if you are white it is are
you less likely to succeed if for
instance you are black will you come
from a Latino Hispanic background and
also as well do you think that
ultimately gave rise to like somebody
like Trump who for you know famously
said that we need to drain the swamp as
it were I think socio-economic
background is very much linked to
privilege so I think there is a racial
element to it but I think a lot of it is
socio-economic so if you're born to a
household with college-educated parents
if your parents are professional workers
entrepreneurs that's going to be a
massive determinant as to whether or not
you become college-educated and move up
in terms of income so and that of course
is linked to race in ethnicity and
racial minorities in America and I think
what's worrying about it obviously lots
of things are worrying about too but one
of the things that's worrying about it
is that America is also the land of
immigrants so is it part of the American
dream is this belief that you could go
to America with nothing and you could
arrive in Ellis Island or angel island
from Italy thank you the Godfather
from Asia and you could literally make
yourself into anything you want to be
and if that isn't actually what the
evidence is suggesting then that is
really striking at the heart of what is
part of the American identity did
President Trump capitalize on this I
think he did to a large extent I think
he realizes that despite America's
overall prosperity there's a lot of
people who feel left behind by the
changes that have caused some of these
trends that were discussing so
globalization is part of the reason why
you see this divide but it's actually
not the biggest factor the biggest
factors technology so technology
automation is why you have a hollowing
out of midscale jobs which is
contributing to stagnant median incomes
and the shrinking of the middle class
but technology is harder it encroaches
it's low it's kind of pervasive but not
in a tangible way it's much harder to
grasp that on the campaign trail
then if to talk about globalization
unfair trade immigration and so I think
a lot of the rise of populism which is
not limited to Trump is related to this
economic malaise that is has
characterized America very quietly but
it's now coming to more of the forefront
it's interesting that the way I think I
did talking about inequality we've
probably said the word inequality about
a hundred times since we started in 10
or 15 minutes we've worked the day that
we're recording this figures have come
out here in the UK by the gender pay gap
and different companies what do you make
about this whole conversation because
the figures that we're seeing
essentially their averages so they don't
take into account the fact that men and
women have different positions it within
companies they're very broad-based
measurements so I imagine for someone
who's in a common economist like you'd
want to drill further down in in order
to understand what they mean what can
you tell us about the gender pay gap
what's causing it what are the different
factors that affect it and I think
there's been a lot of research on why it
is you have a gender pay gap and I'm not
sure that we fully understand it's
but the British government's forcing
companies to declare in quartiles the
pay gap between men and women adds a
huge level of transparency so what you
tend to find in these companies is at
entry-level jobs men and women tend to
be paid around the same the gap is not
huge but as you move up the ranks the
gender pay gap widens and it tends to be
the highest in the top quartile so
without suggesting is that women are not
being promoted to senior positions with
higher pay it could also be suggesting
that women are not as able to ask for
raises or bonuses and partly perhaps
that's a lean in argument that Sheryl
Sandberg has made but maybe it's also an
unconscious bias of on the point of on
the part of employers where if a woman
asks for something maybe it's viewed
less favorably than if a man asked for
it so I think unconscious bias is
probably part of the explanation quite a
lot of the economic studies on gender
suggests that once you control for
observable characteristics such as your
education your occupation your level of
experience your ears in the job even
taking into account labor market
interruption such as if you go and have
children it's still the case there's an
unexplained portion of the gender and
how big is that so it varies across
countries I think the well the British
reporting has given us the most
immediate data I think something like
eight out of ten firms have a
substantial gender pay gap and I think
across industry some of the pay gap is
as small as maybe two-three percent but
if you get into finance construction the
gender pay gap is in the double digits
are we talking about light for light
comparison this is the counter-argument
I'm putting to you because I was
actually on the morning reading the
forums about about this issue because
there was a particular airline I don't
want to mention their names it had a big
one and there were people discussing it
women from both sides and
the arguments that was made by many
people there is when they're making
these comparisons they're not alike for
like comparison so you're not comparing
someone in the same pay grade or someone
in the same position so the reason I'm
asking you is I'm trying to understand
if say to two people man and woman do
the same job and there is that
unexplained difference in their pay what
kind of difference are we talking about
in terms of these people who are doing
exactly the same thing with the same
qualifications and it depends on the
industry and it differs across countries
as well so I think the you know I think
probably as a rough rule of thumb women
are probably paid if you've looked
across studies over a number of years
ten to twenty percent less than men
something like that but it's bigger for
some industries like construction and
finance so what the government's pay
revelations have shown is that they have
it's not a completely comparable but if
you're in the top quartile of wage
earners in a company then you are your
unnie you know without declaring
everybody's income which some countries
in Scandinavia I believe do without
actually declaring everyone's income
there's no way you could do what I
described in economic studies which is
to control for your level of education
your skill your experience unless I
forget as you rise up in corporate ranks
a lot of soft skills are involved which
are very difficult to measure so but
what you do find and this is also part
of the reporting is people in the top
quarter a quartile of income it's also
broken down in terms of numbers of men
and women and there are fewer women in
senior jobs so one other way to look at
it is why are senior positions not being
filled by men and women equally
if they enter at the entry level in
about equal numbers what you find is a
tailing off of women as compared to men
as you move into the top I'm sure there
was an interview which went viral on
channel 4 I'm not sure if you're aware
of
Jordan Peterson is a professor of
psychology at Canadian and he was saying
that the reason that this is big gender
pay gap is that a lot of getting a
higher pay grade is due to
reasonableness and men tend to be more
aggressive when it comes to arguing ago
she ating a salary and he said it is not
as socially acceptable for a woman to
behave in that manner would you think
that would impact it or do you think
it's it's something far more complex I
do think it's well we ascribe things to
unconscious bias it's just sort of a
catch-all because there must be
behaviors that that when men do it it
looks more acceptable than if a woman
were to do it and I can think of
instances where works the other way but
what we do know is unconscious bias also
captures a concept called cognitive
dissonance so people like people who are
like them yes so it's they understand
people who are culturally similar to you
maybe you share an interest in similar
interests and I think that's part of the
unconscious bias or maybe with greater
transparency what that allows people to
do is to say okay have I really thought
hard about the qualifications of the
applicants for this job or how much of
what I'm basing it on is is other
unarticulated traits and where it gets
tricky at the senior levels is that soft
skills of leadership are very hard to
objectively assess whether you're good
manager it's not really something that
comes off your CV because you have so
many years of experience or training and
I think that's why the senior levels you
do find a bigger gender cap both in
terms of income but also in terms of
promotions and employment but quite a
lot of progress has already been made I
think you already see for instance women
going on to bores there's a lot of focus
on
putting women on the executive track so
I think there have been a number of
policies and efforts around this but I
think what's probably we shouldn't
expect is for this issue to be solved
quickly as in now that we see the
numbers I think there's going to be
quite a lot to debate for some time
around why it exists what can be done
about it whether it's you know and and
this is not something it's just
happening here is happening in different
countries around the world
[Music]
you really fascinating article in The
Guardian that I read about the trade war
between the United States and China and
Trump is saying that he wants to
implement it and you think this would be
disastrous for both countries could you
give a little bit of explanation as to
why yeah anything that has I think I
think the difficulty of the us-china
trade tension let's not use war for the
moment is that I think it almost
certainly will raise prices because when
you impose tariffs that's just a fancy
word for tax so you're just going to tax
things and both the US and China
obviously produce a lot of stuff they're
the world's two biggest economy so we're
talking about higher prices and lots of
us buy stuff that are made in China and
made in America so we'll probably be
paying higher prices as well because
they're slapping on like 25 percent
taxes on on products so I think that's
not very good for consumers anywhere and
I think what's potentially really
worrying about the us-china trade
dispute is that they are talking in a
parallel quiet backroom way about
resolving the trade dispute
but that hasn't really stopped these
further rounds of tariffs and the next
stage is going to be restricting
investment and that's potentially really
economically damaging because trade
isn't actually Portugal selling wine to
Britain and Britain you know selling
back textiles trade today is based on
multinational companies setting up
supply chains so apple produces the
iPhone in different parts of the world
it's gets partly finished in China it
gets sent back to the United States so
if you restrict investment you're
affecting firms abilities to decide
where best to locate their production
and that is hard to reverse once you
start down this road of making supply
chain distortions in other words you can
reverse a tariff tomorrow but once an
investment decision is made that's very
difficult to change and that affects
people's employment affects taxes it
affects a local market and so I think
this is all if this is the next step
quite really quite worrying in terms of
where this potential trade war is headed
they're not just looking at terrorists
they're looking at almost the kind of
economic nationalism and this is
somewhat consistent with our president
Trump has said he wants American
companies to bring production back to
America but they went overseas for to
produce things because it was cheaper
and more efficient so that's also going
to raise costs and prices for Americans
and then the final thing I find really
worrying about all of this is who's
going to resolve this this dispute if
the Americans and the Chinese contig Ori
quietly which so far they haven't been
able to agree on how to how to stop this
escalation the World Trade Organization
is the body that oversees global trade
and for that President Trump has
described the WTO as a disaster and if
he pose America out of the WTO I think
that would upend the global trading
system as we know it
the global trading system was actually
formed based on American rules and
American standards but it's provided
more of a level playing field so that
means that a developing country like
Thailand can take America to the WTO to
say your standards on Nets is unfair
that's a protectionist measure has
nothing to do with the nets and that's
exactly what and they won so prom
producers in Thailand couldn't sell
their proms to America because they
weren't using the right kind of nets but
in before the WTO they make that
argument and they win America backs down
if America pulls out then I think we are
really going back to the law of the
jungle which is bilateral resolution and
to me that would be the most worrying
outcome of a potential trade war do you
think that the number one that the
Americans are going to back out and do
you think that Trump's stand against
globalization will work
I think the Treasury the Commerce
Secretary Wilbur Ross has already gone
on air to say even physical shooting
Wars and a negotiation so what they've
been trying to do is to call market so
markets are pretty unhappy at the
escalation attention so and so they're
so I think they're trying to say in town
this is just a way of getting China to
open its markets and to be fair China's
markets are relatively less open than
the United States but it's also not true
that the u.s. is the least protectionist
country in the world the US has the same
tariff levels as the European Union
another target of President Trump so I
think will this will this work for
president Trump in terms of his voters
his electorate I think if he got China
to open up a bit more that would that
would work if the only way to reduce the
trade deficit is to reduce imports make
those more expensive I don't think
that's going to help most of his voters
so there's two ways to reduce a trade
deficit you it's a difference between
exports and imports you can either
import less because it's more expensive
and then therefore your trade deficit
narrows or better export more and that
requires opening up China's market so I
think if you were to open up China's
markets a bit more I think he would view
that as they win but China is a hard
negotiating partner so China is
targeting their tariffs on Trump voters
districts including soybean farmers and
also manufacturing products in the
districts of Congress members of
Congress Wow literally trying to hit
them where it hurts
there's midterm elections coming up in
the United States Congress gets the
House of Representatives is reelected
every two years a third of the Senate is
reelected every two years is six year
terms so you're hitting members of
Congress and saying do you really want
economic damage here especially when the
Republicans are free trade party and
then that would and there's already some
pressure coming from Republicans telling
Trump's you sort of you not escalate
this and remember and this is a really
you know another kind of another step
way outside the normal discussions is
there's even talk in Congress of
restraining the President's powers when
it comes to trade so the President's
powers on trade is a delegated power
from Congress which is the legislative
branch so Congress in theory could
restrict the president's trade powers
I'm sorry in Jordan air that's very
interesting because I was just about to
ask you the opposite because the
opposite movement seems to be happening
in China where the power is centralized
and more in one man's hands and for
however long we don't know what is
happening in China and why is it
happening in terms of the political
structure and system well President Xi
Jingping has I think set him up set
himself up to be President indefinitely
I think president Trump joked that
something they should try in America yes
I think I think Xi Jinping is
politically very powerful that's clear
from what he's been able to to do one of
the I think challenges around whether he
can really be president indefinitely is
that one of the tricky things about
China's economic development is that
it's happened without political reform
in any substantive way so it was oh it's
always the case as the country becomes
richer people need their policymakers to
be accountable and if you have a
president you can't get rid of before
Chinese elections or not really
elections presidents served two
five-year terms and I'm from Russia I
know what you're talking so I'm not
suggesting that it was you know that may
not be much different than it was but I
think but China is now richer than it
was thirty forty years ago so if you
don't have a safety valve for people's
dissatisfaction then delivering on the
economy becomes very important right and
Xi Jinping has really focused on local
official corruption to try and because
he knows that's an area that I'm that
the Chinese people are just very unhappy
with local officials you know taking
their possessions being arbitrary all of
violent all of those things so it's his
policies are trying to keep him in power
stabilize the system address where the
lot of the grievances are but I suppose
that the economy slows down will the
system work and I suppose every time I
think about you know where China is
headed to me that's one of the biggest
unknowns which is at some point most
economies have to have some degree of
rule of law that's independent from the
politicians so people can protect their
homes protect their livelihoods and in
China that's very weak and that's
unlikely to get any stronger and once
you have centralized political power
it's very hard to see a judiciary that
might be able to stand up
the executive do you think that China
will ever become a democracy or do you
think that's a for loan hope for our
lifetime in particular I find these
things really hard to predict the
history if you look around East Asia is
that countries have become democracies
through a really rocky part so if you
look at South Korea if you look at
Taiwan it's a it's one of those things
where I said remember the Arab Spring
when we first had the initial you know
pretty small incident in Tunisia as and
it wasn't here square straight off and
it's just really hard to predict what
could spark something that really brings
about change but no at the moment I
think China has his own version of
democracy as an intra-party competition
but that's being eroded by Xi Jinping's
centralization of his power so you know
like like the Arab Spring I find this
area very very difficult to to assess
and predict well of course an advantage
of a more authoritarian system is
continuity and strength and power as a
country isn't there is that element and
do you think what's happening in North
Korea now is an example of China flexing
its muscles essentially I think with
north well I think North Korea is has
been a headache
for some time for China because it's a
very unstable regime on their doorstep
the bulwark between it and South Korea
which is aligned to the United States
this is left over from the Cold War and
I think whether there's no question that
China is the most influential player
when it comes to North Korea and the
fact that the North Korean leader made a
initially quite quiet trip to Beijing
where nobody was sure if he was there or
not you know in a train probably suggest
that China is indeed powerful in this
respect because he was they discussed
what might be discussed between
President Trump and Kim jong-un and
there's never been a meeting between the
North Korea leader and the President of
the United States but the North Korean
leader went to China first - and that
tells you a lot by the way if President
Trump were to sit down with Kim Jong on
and they resolved the North Korea issue
I mean like wow I was just gonna ask you
that that could be a huge success story
for Donald Trump could it not if that
were to be achieved yeah if you did
nuclearized North Korea if you
normalized it but here's another part
that would be interesting so say they
have the summit and North Korea agrees
to dismantle its nuclear weapons which
okay this is all bit of a long shot and
it begins to talk about reunification
with South Korea a unified Korea which
is attached in terms of a land border to
China isn't necessarily something the
Chinese would want because a unified
Korea is probably going to be a Western
orientated and so China would want the
status quo and so even if the South
Koreans and the Americans think the only
way to stabilize North Korea would be to
remove the DMZ normalize integrate all
the kinds of things they've been hoping
to do for a very long time I wonder how
much support they would get from China
for that because China would be worried
about having a it's so clearly US
orientated country that is on their
doorstep so I think the status quo would
be what the Chinese would want and I
think realistically that's probably what
we'll end up with but who knows well in
other possibilities has been mooted of
course is the idea of a soft annexation
of North Korea by China which kind of
allows the West to say well it's been
dealt with the Chinese are controlling
the Chinese don't have a unified career
on their border sitting there
frustrating them because it's a Western
ally do you think that might happen do
you think Donald Trump because that's
never happened before
because the West hasn't probably wanted
that to happen
but now Donald Trump is kind of pulled
back America's influence could that
happen is that something that the
Chinese would go for and would be
interested in I think they would still
prefer the status quo I think taking
responsibility for a regime that because
essentially you would have to take
responsibility for the Kim regime I
think it's probably a step they'd be
very quite unwilling to take so the
Chinese have operated for a long time
based on a doctrine of non-interference
they don't interfere in the affairs of
other countries and by implication you
don't interfere in the affairs of China
for example mess with the congressional
districts in the okay and another thing
on China that we wanted to talk to you
about as well is there's been a lot in
the news recently about the Social
Credit System can you tell anyone who
doesn't know anything about it like us
what it is why it's happening what are
the consequences of it just anything
really
it's very big brother-ish of course now
we've realized with Facebook I think
well the Chinese control the internet
pretty closely so the great Chinese
firewall I think is pretty well known
but they also monitor pretty actively
what's posted on the Internet so this
idea the social credit system is if
you're a good citizen then they're going
to develop a digital profile of you that
could end up getting you cheaper train
tickets if you're good or things like
that how do they measure your good
citizenship how do you tell if someone
is a good citizen oh yeah it's a good
question
probably I guess if you post good things
about the country you're like if you're
jaywalking if you're walking on the
street rather than the pavement this
facial recognition cameras can tell that
you're doing that and that affect your
credit is this just kind of conspiracy
stuff or is that part of the package Oh
we'll have to see it's very hard to know
what they're actually I'm sure they're
monitoring all of that but what goes
into the algorithm I don't really know
but it is worrying the big
brother-ish and I think when they first
I'm started discussing the system I
think a lot of people were thinking oh
my gosh you know this is really yeah
this is all well Yin
and then we find out that in the West
we've been tracked digitally as well and
now I kind of feel in general we are
obviously not it's not as Extreme as
what China is proposing but I think our
yeah I think our digital lies have been
tracked probably far more than we
realize
one thing I found very interesting when
I visited China which was a few years
ago it was 2006 is the division in one
thing we have it in all societies to a
certain degree but horrendous difference
between rich and poor like going to a
mall in Beijing and it was like us I
mean by walked into one shop but it was
like a superstore for Gucci and just
people buying just bags and bags and
bags and bags of you know the products
you know Gucci products that worth
literally thousands and thousands of
dollars and then you go outside and
there were people there with unable to
afford a bowl of rice I mean surely that
must create tension in society where you
have this ostentatious display of wealth
and then you have extreme poverty
especially and somebody told me they
looked down a mean I might be wrong with
this they make the Chinese society looks
down on people who are from rural or
agricultural backgrounds yeah I think
they I think for quite a long time
urban dwellers think that migrant
workers you know from the countryside
they do the kind of menial tasks
inequality in China is a massive problem
at one point China was more unequal than
the United States by a measure of what's
called the Gini coefficient which
measures inequality that's extraordinary
China is a communist country everybody's
supposed to be equal right so I think
one of the one of the challenges that Xi
Jinping's administration is going to
have to try and face is when you have I
mean income inequality has already has
plateaued it's actually not gotten worse
but it's plateaued at a very high level
is what they would do about it and it's
not clear a lot has been done about it
but in China you also now have and this
is under ceding pains one of his
policies and they talk about the Chinese
dream which is even if you are from the
countryside and you're a migrant worker
then you too can have a house a picket
fence a car a good job so it's basically
a mirror of the American dream and so in
in that in that way Communist China is
very similar to capitalist America
because they're both not going to reduce
inequality in the way that you would see
Northern Europe which is more equal
because governments redistribute incomes
to reduce inequality both America and
China seem to be using social mobility
and Economic Opportunity as a way of
counteracting very high levels of
inequality I'm not sure that we'll see
how it works out I'm not sure that is
going to be socially acceptable given
how vast the income divide is in a
country which is still only a
middle-income country so it's not a
sieve on average people are well-off on
average averaging comes out nine
thousand US dollars per year so still
developing emerging economy to have this
kind of inequality we'll see how it sits
but I think the
prognosis for it is that they're eating
like they're going down the American
route I will do one more question China
will move on I remember didn't kill Ed
Koch anomic hosting a discussion between
you and other experts on the subject of
China and one of the things that I
remember absolutely struck me is that
I'd come into into the conversation
thinking that China's this big threat to
the West and everything else and what
emerged as actually observes a lot of
one of the contributions that you made
is the idea that China's financial
system is got a lot of problems in it
and those problems could affect China
which then would affect the rest of the
world and basically the idea being that
China's biggest threat to the world it's
not it's intentional actions it's the
collapse of its financial system
potentially can you talk a little bit
about that and tell us what that what
that's about
yeah so I think China is likely to have
a financial crisis all major economies
do the only question is how big and when
and I don't know the answer to warning
about quite a long time and that's
because they have such a legacy of debt
from different you know they've been
massive buildups of debt since the 2008
crisis so I think it matters a lot for
the rest of the world because China's
the world's second-biggest economy and
we know that countries when they have a
financial crisis and again this depends
on the scale but data and China isn't
very good and so if China ends up having
to you know deal with a banking crisis
or something like that the economy is
likely to stagnate and for a lot of
countries the stagnation is a decade or
in the japan's case two decades three
decades and that would really be a
massive drag on the rest of the world in
terms of growth because china at the
moment is a bigger contributor to
driving global growth than america and
so we should all be quite concerned that
China whether China can deal with this
debt problem maybe it can
but I wouldn't rule out any major
economy having a financial crisis
stemming from some something it's just
it's very unusual not to have one it's
more usual to have one there's a book by
Reinhart and Rogoff where they basically
track over the last two centuries all
major economies have crises at some
point and China in its current form
since market-oriented reforms started in
78 has not had a crisis that's a it's a
very long run so hopefully it'll
continue one of the things that you've
talked about a lot in in your talks and
in your lectures is the process of
ending global poverty and you've
mentioned the fact that a lot of
progress has been made and I think
you've said that since 1990 about a
billion people have been lifted out of
extreme poverty and then obviously if
you go back to kind of the start of
capitalism it's pretty much most of the
world has been lifted out of extreme
poverty where are we with that and
what's happening and what and also how
is that happening unevenly around the
world because that's also another issue
that you mentioned in terms of Africa
and China and so on yeah so the end of
poverty was my TEDx talk and probably
the the two things that I stressed there
is we have a very ambitious target to
end extreme poverty by 2030 that's been
adopted by the United Nations and all
countries around the world but the
second thing I stress is past
performance doesn't necessarily predict
future performance and the reason is
because we are at a historic point one
out of ten people live in extreme
poverty less than a dollar 90 per day
adjusted for what a dollar buys in their
country that's the lowest it's been in
around the world through history but a
lot of that is due to China's remarkable
growth and growth in East Asia what you
found so you mentioned there one of the
room the stats is since 1990 a billion
people have been lifted out of abject
poverty but since 1990 sub-saharan
Africa has seen the absolute number of
people in poverty increase even though
it was the second fastest growing region
in the world after Asia so growth if
it's unequal benefits people who are
rich and it doesn't lift those at the
bottom so yes
growth in China and East Asia is why
we're at this historic point but to
eradicate poverty requires lifting the
remaining seven hundred sixty-seven
million people half of whom are found in
sub-saharan Africa out of poverty and
what you've worked before probably what
didn't work - to raise Africans out of
poverty over the past few decades so
it's unlikely is we need to try
something else
looking forward but the good news is
most people recognize that that to deal
with poverty now in Africa and in South
Asia is going to have to you're going to
have to think of new models new ways of
incorporating for instance what I think
of as more grassroots civil society
organizations they're reducing
inequality as part of that but I think
there is a recognition that something
different has to be done because what's
been done before just well it hasn't
worked well China growing more is not so
gonna solve the problem of poor people
in Africa as basic and growth although
in Africa isn't going to do it so we're
gonna have to think of new ways of doing
it
and why is that why is that different in
Africa as opposed to somewhere in other
places why is it growth that doesn't
have the same impact
part of it is inequality so
if growth happens and the benefits
accrue to the rich then that has that'll
raise the growth rate of the economy
it'll increase GDP but the benefits
don't go to those who are poor and
therefore they remain poor the answer
also even countries which like Tanzania
is not subject is not in the midst of
conflict their numbers of people in
poverty have increased as well so it's
not the kind of the correlates we
typically look at are not the reasons
are not going to be enough you can't
just focus on no conflict or promoting
growth to to lift people out of poverty
so there's no easy answer to what needs
to be done but I think there is a
widespread recognition that economic
development is going to have to look
harder at institutions so these
grassroots groups that I referred to
it's something is one of my actually the
chapter one of the chapters in my book
is is entitled why are so few countries
prosperous and the answer part of the
answer is that the institutions in these
countries need to reform so we've been
focused economists focus a lot on growth
but actually it's about trying to get
the institutions to work better if
that's means using social capital or
social networks or some other way to
make growth more inclusive but because
there is a recognition that something
different has to be done it is possible
given how much nations around the world
our focus on this that we could end up
by 2030 eradicating poverty or most
extreme poverty and on current trends we
will by 2030 live in a world where for
the first time more than half of the
global population is middle class that
means earning between 10 to a hundred
dollars per day
it basically means you can afford a
refrigerator
but I think you know we are on the cusp
of and potentially an a transformative
period in the world because there is I
think yeah a recognition that we need to
think differently about it and and I'm
always very hopeful that we will get to
this point where we'll see hundreds of
millions of people in the middle class
in fact I think the projections by the
OECD are that there'll be four point
nine billion people who are in the
middle class out of a global population
of eight point six billion in 2030 and
that would be extraordinary the one
thing we do like to do at the end of the
shows we always curious because we ask
you questions that we think are
interesting but actually were constantly
aware that we may not know the most
interesting question so what we'd like
to ask is is a an issue or several
issues that you think we ought to be
talking about it ought to be focusing on
that actually no one is talking about
and no one is focusing on is there
something like that that you want to
bring to our attention I think probably
well this is an issue that lots of
people do talk about but I think we
should talk about it more is the
question of wire wages so low so that's
also a chapter in my book and the reason
I think this question is important is
because typically when you if you look
at what matters in economics there has
to be people's standard of living so
when you look at these this question of
why wages have not kept up with
productivity it gets you into this whole
world of trends that we know is
affecting our livelihoods but I don't
know that we've done enough research or
analysis to understand some of these
trends so for instance we've talked
about globalization and a bit on
technology but technology is one of the
the biggest issues around what happens
to the world of work and automation is
one of the issues that's causing this
hollowing out amid skilled jobs and then
therefore depressing median wages so I
think that's a massive issue and another
component of why wages are so low
is that workers in terms of bargaining
power have been getting less so if you
look at the share of income for instance
in America the trend is very clear the
share of income going to owners of
capital has been rising the share of
income going to workers has been falling
so why are workers losing bargaining
power and that's also contributing to to
their low wages and this then all gets
tied up into this dissatisfaction that
people rightly have if they feel they're
being left behind by the growth of a
country so the the populist movements
we've seen in America and other parts of
Europe I think do reflect the fact that
people do not feel and they would be
right they're not better off than they
were years ago but we're not I think
thinking hard enough about what what to
do about these trends and I think
bargaining powerful workers is one of
the hardest things the there is a
correlation with unionization but that's
not the whole answer either because you
don't have as I say kind of a simple
solution to it
but until we get a hold of why it is
that people are not being paid what
they're actually producing so that's
what it means for wages to keep up with
productivity that they're going to be
dissatisfied with the status quo they're
dissatisfied with the status quo then
you can get electorate switch and start
to throw out the policymakers they view
as part of the establishment and this
kind of anti-establishment political
mood is linked to people's economic
circumstances and just because you live
in a rich country it doesn't necessarily
mean you feel better off so to me this
issue around low productivity slow
growth and wages is one that we should
be much more focused on there you go
you're not being paid enough yeah for
brexit well done yeah so that was
absolutely fascinating there thank you
so much if you'd like to promote
anything your Twitter handle or maybe
we'll have it up on the videos yeah it's
a Delinda you isn't it simply that Linda
has a great book coming out it's out
already I'm reading it I'm really in
so I recommend anyone buys that thank
you so much for coming in has been an
absolute pleasure we really appreciate
it and if people want to follow you on
twitter a constant and Kissin and I'm
failing human so give me a follow on
there and well thank you very much for
listening and watching if you liked it
please follow click subscribe share it
promote it retweet it all the rest of it
and thank you very much
[Music]